but let's begin here in South Florida
where torrential rain caused major
flooding overnight a rare flash flood
emergency alert warned of
life-threatening conditions after
torrential rain made roads impossible to
navigate and trap people in their cars
it's being called a one in a thousand
year flood event and what will jorgeous
is in Fort Lauderdale which is still
flooded this morning Manny good morning
good morning we're at the airport and
behind me you can see why it remains
shut down there's water covering the
tarmac but also back there what
resembles a big lake right now that's
the runway it is submerged and the
airport is not scheduled to reopen until
at least noon today this area got more
than 26 inches of rain in just an
eight-hour period to put that into
perspective that's about 40 percent of
their annual rainfall in just one day
some South Florida streets resembled
Rivers Wednesday I've never seen this
much rain leaving cars either stuck
nearly submerged or even abandoned I see
like 20 cars stall out and uh guys I
tell one guy don't drive
inundated roads force people to Wade
through knee-high Waters some even
plunging in just across the street now
is not the time to be on the roadway
authorities are urging residents to seek
Higher Ground and stay off the roads
look at these houses Rising water from
the Relentless rain swamped this
Hospital parking lot in Fort Lauderdale
and flooded many garages like Andra
cicadis I've lived here for the last
four years and as much rain as we get
this is this is the worst I've ever seen
it planes were grounded at Fort
Lauderdale International Airport where
nearly 200 flights were canceled
yesterday many passengers were stranded
and packed into terminals overnight
sleeping wherever they could we're
trying to get back home and they're
telling us that the airport is closed
and so at this point we don't know what
to do
overnight the airport reopened the
departures level so passengers could
leave if they wish another problem today
Broward County Schools will have to
close due to the weather Tony
all right Manny thank you very much and